لم يكن لكثير من الاتراك ان يالفوا مشهدا
كهذا كمال كلش المرشح الرئاسي عن المعارضه
في لافته واحده مع امراه محجبه
لمنافسيه ممن لم ينسوا سنوات التضييق
ضروره الانتخابيه ليس الا بينما يرى فيه
حلفاؤه تسامحا واعترافا بحريه المراه
هذا ليس تغيرا في الخطاب تجاوزنا التمييز
بين النساء على اساس الحجاب منذ زمن
ولدينا مرشحات محجبات وحقوق النساء جزء
اصيل لدينا
كلام كهذا قد لا يكفي لتبديد مخاوف البعض
لذا تتبنى المعارضه برنامجا انتخابيا
يتوزع بين حمايه المراه اجتماعيا ودعمها
اقتصاديا ومنحها فرصا متكافئه في التوظيف
والنظام الصحي
على الطرف المقابل يستند حزب العداله
والتنميه على ما يصفها بالانجازات خلال
عهده
مرشحه الحزب للبرلمان تنزل الى الشارع في
ظل وجود جدل وانقسام سياسي واجتماعي بشان
المراه
متساويه في التوظيف ورفع نسبه التعليم
والتمثيل السياسي وسنسعى لضمان حقوق
المراه وتكافؤ الفرص لكن انسحاب حكومه
العداله والتنميه من اتفاقيه اسطنبول
الخاصه بحقوق المراه فتح الباب امام جدل
بين حكومه تخشى على المجتمع من القيم
الغربيه ومعارضه تخشى زياده التعنيف
وتقييد الحريات قضايا المراه بعيون
المرشحين ستؤثر على اراء الناخبين ليس من
باب حساسيتها وحسب وانما لكون المراه تشكل
نصف عدد السكان ونصف عدد من يحق لهم
التصويت
دور النساء مفصليون بسبب ادراكهن لحقوقهن
والاقتراع سيتاثر بذلك وبالاضافه لقضيه
الحجاب هناك مطالب اق تتعلق بحجم فرص عمل
النساء لا تخلو اي حمله انتخابيه لاي حزب
من حضور المراه كما
تحضر لجدل انتخابي لكن الناشطات التركيه
يطالبنا بان يرتقي التمثيل السياسي للنساء
ليصل الى وزنهن الانتخابي فرح الزمن شوقي
الجزيره انقره